Alice:没杯子呢
Alice: There's no cup.
Alice:拿个碗吧
Alice: Get a bowl instead.
Alice:这个吗
Alice: This one?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 直接倒就好
Shure: Just pour it directly.
Shure: 倒了一点醋
Shure: Poured a bit of vinegar.
Shure: 怎么样
Shure: How is it?
Shure: 评价一下吧
Shure: Give it a review.
Shure: 喝不惯是吧
Shure: Not used to drinking it, right?
Alice:太酸了
Alice: Too sour.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Alice:感觉跟冲的还是不一样
Alice: Feels different from the mixed one.
Alice:比它好喝
Alice: Tastes better than this.
Alice:但是你喜欢酸的吗
Alice: But do you like sour things?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后这种
Shure: And this kind...
Shure: 他能喝出来一些其他的花果香
Shure: He can taste some other floral and fruity notes.
Alice:嗯确实有点后味
Alice: Hmm, it does have a bit of an aftertaste.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:昨天你好像也早上就咬到了嘴是吧
Jake: Yesterday you bit your lip in the morning too, right?
Katrina: 回龙关在哪
Katrina: Where is Huilongguan?
Shure: 回龙观
Shure: Huilongguan.
Alice:在北边
Alice: It's to the north.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Alice:靠靠北
Alice: All the way north.
Katrina: 哦那离离那个西直门远吗
Katrina: Oh, is it far from Xizhimen?
Shure: 离沙河
Shure: It's near Shahe.
Alice:离西直门
Alice: From Xizhimen.
Alice:说远不远说近不近
Alice: Not too far, not too close.
Alice:得一个多小时
Alice: It takes about an hour.
Katrina: 啊，这么远
Katrina: Ah, that far?
Shure: 不不到一个小时
Shure: No, less than an hour.
Alice:一个吧
Alice: About an hour.
Shure: 坐十三号线就就可以回龙观
Shure: Just take Line 13 to Huilongguan.
Katrina: 回龙关到西直门
Katrina: From Huilongguan to Xizhimen.
Katrina: 八寨
Katrina: Bajie.
Shure: 对 31分钟
Shure: Yes, 31 minutes.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 你看看
Shure: Look at this.
Alice:牛逼啊
Alice: Awesome.
Shure: local我跟你讲
Shure: Local, I'm telling you.
Katrina: logo哈哈哈
Katrina: Logo, hahaha.
Alice:确实没办法我们这
Alice: Indeed, there's no way for us.
Shure: 没办法我们这
Shure: No way for us.
Katrina: 你们你们校区在哪啊
Katrina: Where's your campus?
Katrina: 我们只有一个校区嗯
Katrina: We only have one campus, hmm.
Alice:我们只有一个校区在村
Alice: We only have one campus in the village.
Shure: 是吗
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 在离这其实挺近
Katrina: 在昌平啊
Katrina: In Changping?
Alice:在朝阳离这很近
Alice: In Chaoyang, very close to here.
Katrina: 哦哦哦中场我找
Katrina: Oh, oh, I found it at halftime.
Katrina: 我当时就定的中场附近的酒店
Katrina: I booked a hotel near halftime.
Katrina: 去那个环球影城来着
Katrina: To go to Universal Studios.
Katrina: 然后然后在旁边麦当劳
Katrina: And then next to McDonald's.
Katrina: 晚上12点巨多人
Katrina: It was super crowded at midnight.
Katrina: 全是学生
Katrina: All students.
Shure: 来吧家人们
Shure: Come on, folks.
Shure: 尝尝这个地道的老北京美食
Shure: Try this authentic old Beijing cuisine.
Alice:是你们学校的吗
Alice: Is it from your school?
Shure: 对没错
Shure: Yeah, that's right.
Alice:对你们学校
Alice: Right, your school.
Alice:包子真有那么好吃
Alice: Are the buns really that good?
Shure: 不知道他能吃32个
Shure: I don't know, he can eat 32 of them.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 我也是是个那他
Shure: I'm also... he...
Katrina: 他一个人吃32个
Katrina: He ate 32 by himself?
Shure: 我不知道他为什么要点32个洗
Shure: I don't know why he ordered 32.
Lucia: 哎这个葡萄洗好了吗谢谢大
Lucia: Hey, are these grapes washed? Thanks a lot.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:因为如果是食堂的包子话
Alice: Because if they're from the cafeteria...
Alice:应该有那个什么补助之类的
Alice: There should be some kind of subsidy or something.
Shure: 反正就这么大的那种
Shure: Anyway, they're about this big.
Shure: 包子什么馅啊
Shure: What filling do the buns have?
Alice:什么馅啊
Alice: What filling is it?
Shure: 有牛肉馅
Shure: It's beef filling.
Alice:有这么好吃
Alice: Is it that delicious?
Katrina: 拖家带口的
Katrina: Bringing the whole family.
Shure: 还行吧我只能说我那天尝尝了一口
Shure: It's alright, I can only say I tried a bite that day.
Alice:你吃过吗
Alice: Have you eaten it?
Shure: 只有正常包子味
Shure: It just tastes like normal buns.
Shure: 没有什么特别的感觉
Shure: Nothing particularly special.
Shure: 搞不懂
Shure: I don't get it.
Alice:你们最近是不是开了一个什么自创
Alice: Did you guys recently open some kind of...
Alice:那个什么自那个那个文创店
Alice: What was it, a cultural and creative store?
Shure: 恩
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:刷到了
Alice: I saw it online.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 那事都顶到热搜第二了天
Alice:撤的也挺快
Alice: It got taken down pretty quickly.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:就是一个很很很很会
Alice: Just someone who's really good at...
Alice:他们需要的啊
Alice: They need that.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Alice:你们不知道吗不知道
Alice: You guys didn't know? Didn't know?
Lucia: 不知道我最近没怎么刷
Lucia: I didn't, I haven't been browsing much lately.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Alice:文娱知识
Alice: Entertainment news.
Alice:不对不是不是知识
Alice: No, no, not news.
Alice:文娱八卦之类的
Alice: More like entertainment gossip.
Lucia: 最近几天太忙了都没有刷这些软件
Lucia: I've been too busy these days to check those apps.
Shure: 是上上周的事
Shure: It was from the week before last.
Shure: 就来之前的事了应该是
Shure: Should have been before you came.
Lucia: ah OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
Alice:你之后要去哪读书啊
Alice: Where are you going to study next?
Katrina: 我去南京
Katrina: I'm going to Nanjing.
Katrina: 我去东南那边
Katrina: I'm going to Southeast University.
Shure: 哎有书读啊真好啊
Shure: Ah, it's great to have a school to go to.
Lucia: 哦原来这是肥肠
Lucia: Oh, so this is pork intestines.
Lucia: 帮我解锁一下
Lucia: Help me unlock it.
Lucia: 一种新食物
Lucia: A new kind of food.
Katrina: 拿瓦分是吗
Katrina: We should use a bowl to portion it, right?
Shure: 拿碗分吧
Shure: Yeah, use a bowl to portion it.
Shure: 你别一下又打了啊
Shure: Don't hit it all at once again.
Shure: 我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina: 我爸是
Katrina: My dad is...
Shure: 这是谁谁的电脑
Shure: Whose computer is this?
Shure: 说一下吧
Shure: Just tell me.
Shure: 华发
Shure: Huafa.
Shure: 谁的华发
Shure: Whose Huafa is this?
Shure: 啊他傻的电脑是吗
Shure: Ah, is this his computer?
Shure: 他昨天不会来打游戏来了吧
Shure: He couldn't come to play games yesterday, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:打完游戏抢红包贼开心
Jake: After playing games, he was so happy to grab the red envelopes.
Shure: 你在这打游戏来着是吗
Shure: You were playing games here, right?
Shure: 收下收下
Shure: Accept it, accept it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: 23
Lucia: 23.
Shure: i need
Shure: I need...
Shure: some t恤
Shure: Some t-shirts.
Shure: 上面没有t恤了杨老板
Shure: There are no more t-shirts upstairs, Jake.
Shure: 哎我今天早上拿出来一个
Shure: Hey, I took one out this morning.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上拿上来一包好像
Lucia: Hey, I think I brought a pack up this morning.
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: This one is...
Jake:他这有貔貅吗
Jake: Does he have a Pixiu?
Shure: 他这个是
Shure: This one is...
Lucia: 哎没有吗
Lucia: Hey, no?
Lucia: 那我再拿一把
Lucia: Then I'll get another pack.
Jake:不是就是外卖
Jake: No, it's just takeout.
Shure: 七尘vips
Shure: Seven Dust VIPs.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Jake:这里还有一些遗留溪秀
Jake: There are still some left over here.
Shure: 好主要主要
Shure: Alright, mainly, mainly...
Jake:你看
Jake: Look.
Shure: 把筷子擦干净
Shure: Wipe the chopsticks clean.
Jake:凑一凑长一长
Jake: Gather and extend them.
Lucia: 这还没有两包
Lucia: This isn't even two packs.
Lucia: 那就拿这个吧
Lucia: Let's just take this one.
Shure: 那筷子
Shure: Those chopsticks...
Shure: 能使吗
Shure: Can we use them?
Lucia: 头发怎么这么乱
Lucia: Why is your hair so messy?
Shure: 还要使刷一下
Shure: It needs a brush.
Tasha: 稍微冲一下吧
Tasha: Just rinse it a bit.
Alice:哪个呀
Alice: Which one?
Alice:这是
Alice: This one?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 刷一下吧
Shure: Brush it.
Alice:我考
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake:你之前炒过鸡吗
Jake: Have you ever stir-fried chicken before?
Jake:没有我炒过狗狗的鸡我靠
Jake: No, but I've stir-fried my dog's chicken, oh my god.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 最多赚了快1万
Shure: 最后1分钱没赚
Shure: But in the end, I didn't make a penny.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:我们钱币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Alice:我们钱
Alice: Our money...
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Jake:我们货币即将发售
Jake: Our currency is about to be released.
Shure: 我们的币子上链了家人们
Shure: Our currency is now on the blockchain, everyone.
Jake:大家大家忘掉这件事情
Jake: Everyone, everyone, forget about this.
Jake:忘掉这件事情10年之后才想起来
Jake: Forget about this and remember it in 10 years.
Shure: 然后就发现自己富了是吗
Shure: And then you'll realize you're rich, right?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 财务自由
Shure: Financial freedom.
Jake:财务自由职业自由
Jake: Financial freedom, career freedom.
Shure: 直接自由
Shure: Absolute freedom.
Shure: 真的会吗杨老板
Shure: Will it really happen, Jake?
Tasha: 往我的账户里面先充5050个
Tasha: First, transfer 5050 units to my account.
Jake:拢共150个
Jake: A total of 150 units.
Shure: 那这个
Shure: Then this...
Shure: 什么时候能让我实现财富自由呢
Shure: When will I be able to achieve financial freedom?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake?
Jake:那就得
Jake: Well...
Alice:快的话今晚就可以
Alice: If things go well, tonight.
Jake:你
Jake: You...
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 呵呵呵不是
Shure: Haha, no.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么做的这个哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, how did you do this? Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这已经开始画饼了是吧
Lucia: Haha, you’re already making big promises, huh?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：你今天晚上你先选一个别的比好
Others: Tonight, you should pick something else first.
Tasha: 少个凳子
Tasha: We're missing a chair.
Shure: 好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 再来个凳子
Tasha: Let's get another chair.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:好吃吗火烧
Jake: Is the roasted bun tasty?
Jake:好吃
Jake: Tasty.
Lucia: 我来分发一下
Lucia: Let me distribute this.
Jake:驴肉对
Jake: It's donkey meat, right?
Jake:这就是驴肉
Jake: This is donkey meat.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 要个这个就行了
Tasha: Just give me this, it's fine.
Tasha: 我不要筷子了
Tasha: I don't need chopsticks.
Lucia: 啊那那给给健康好了
Lucia: Ah, well, give it to Healthy then.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那这筷子就放这
Lucia: Then I'll just put these chopsticks here.
Jake:我我还有
Jake: I, I still have...
Jake:我还有一套餐具
Jake: I still have a set of utensils.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 是呢
Shure: Oh, really?
Jake:是吗这是我的啊
Jake: Really, this is mine.
Tasha: 这这还有筷子呢
Tasha: There are chopsticks here too.
Lucia: 啊刚刚不是给你了一套
Lucia: Ah, didn't I just give you a set?
Jake:这是啊这不是我
Jake: This, ah, this isn't mine.
Lucia: 笑死了我刚还以为你有两个
Lucia: I'm dying of laughter, I thought you had two.
Jake:我有两个人
Jake: I have two people.
Lucia: 人哈哈哈
Lucia: People, hahaha.
Shure: 卤煮火烧
Shure: Braised meat bun.
Tasha: 你要吃这个是吗
Tasha: You want to eat this, right?
Jake:呃我也吃火烧
Jake: Uh, I'll have the roasted bun too.
Jake:今晚吃什么
Jake: What are we having for dinner?
Shure: 买麦当劳汉堡
Shure: Buy McDonald's burgers.
Jake:麦麦当劳汉堡是吧
Jake: McDonald's burgers, right?
Tasha: 嘿嘿
Tasha: Hehe.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 你们这边有了吗
Shure: Do you have it here?
Lucia: 你们这边有了吗
Lucia: Do you have it here?
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake:我们吃过麦当劳汉堡吗
Jake: Have we had McDonald's burgers before?
Shure: 啊我先不要
Shure: Ah, I don't want it yet.
Jake:还肯德基
Jake: And KFC.
Shure: 我先等着
Shure: I'll wait first.
Jake:第一天肯德基是吧
Jake: First day, KFC, right?
Lucia: 那我吃了
Lucia: Then I'll eat it.
Shure: 那我吃了嗯
Shure: Then I'll eat it, yeah.
Shure: 要加点蒜泥吗
Shure: Do you want to add some garlic paste?
Shure: 有
Shure: Got it.
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Got it?
其他愉：中了还来得及浇吧
Other: If it's successful, there's still time to pour it, right?
Shure: 来得及我今天早上刚浇
Shure: There's time, I just watered it this morning.
其他人：明天才结束
Others: It ends tomorrow.
Shure: 你就搬一个标题
Shure: Just move a title.
其他人：懒
Others: Lazy.
Shure: 哎懒死你得了
Shure: Hey, you're so lazy.
Shure: 这里呢你帮忙拿一个蒜泥
Shure: Here, help me get some garlic paste.
Shure: 首先倒倒倒里了
Shure: First, pour it in, pour it in.
Tasha: 啊我只是想要一个娃哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I just want a Wahaha.
Shure: 倒倒这里我给你开了一瓶
Shure: Pour it in here, I opened a bottle for you.
Lucia: 我给你开了一瓶
Lucia: I opened a bottle for you.
Shure: 你还没喝呢
Shure: You haven't drunk it yet.
Lucia: 娃哈哈你还没喝呢
Lucia: Wahaha, you haven't drunk it yet.
Shure: 这韭菜花先不用
Shure: No need for the chive flowers yet.
Shure: 嗯倒倒倒
Shure: Yeah, pour it in, pour it in.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 一点都挺好
Shure: It's all good.
其他人：我记得我记得刚刚早期的时候
Others: I remember, I remember in the early days.
Alice:还有个俘虏
Alice: There was also a prisoner.
其他人：他早期
Others: In the early days.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
其他人：他早期的时候不是已经这样吗
Others: Wasn't it like this in the early days?
Alice:这个要吗
Alice: Do you want this?
其他人：不要不要
Others: No, no.
其他人：放着好
Others: Just leave it.
其他人：他早期的时候不是有过中文吗
Others: Didn't they have Chinese in the early days?
其他人：明天又要搞一个
Others: Tomorrow, they'll do another one.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Lucia: 那要加香菜吗
Lucia: Should we add cilantro?
Shure: 呃他啥不吃啊
Shure: Uh, what doesn't he eat?
Lucia: 他们那有
Lucia: They have it there.
Lucia: 有一碗那就不加
Lucia: If there's one bowl, then don't add it.
Lucia: 辣椒油
Lucia: Chili oil.
Shure: 辣椒油可以
Shure: Chili oil is fine.
Shure: 整 一点
Shure: Add a little.
Lucia: 这是啥呀哦
Lucia: What is this? Oh.
Shure: 辣椒油
Shure: Chili oil.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: a d钙是吗
Shure: Is it A and D calcium?
Shure: 可以来一瓶
Shure: Can I get a bottle?
Shure: 有北冰洋吗
Shure: Do you have Beibingyang?
Alice:楼上有
Alice: There's some upstairs.
其他人：直接有人带上来
Others: Someone will bring it up directly.
Shure: 我要要北冰洋
Shure: I want Beibingyang.
其他人：谢谢
Others: Thank you.
Jake:这卤乳是不是得有勺啊
Jake: Does this braised tofu need a spoon?
其他人：不用啊
Others: No, it doesn't.
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Katrina: 那有勺也可以用
Katrina: But you can use a spoon if you have one.
Jake:啊有勺
Jake: Ah, there's a spoon.
Jake:哦原来有勺可以
Jake: Oh, there's a spoon, that's fine.
Shure: 他火烧好像都在底下
Shure: The roasted ones seem to be at the bottom.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
其他人：我觉得这个比表演的好吃
Others: I think this tastes better than the performance one.
Jake:比什么
Jake: Better than what?
Shure: 这个吗嗯
Shure: This one? Hmm.
Shure: 没有有
Shure: Not really.
Shure: 这不正宗
Shure: This isn't authentic.
Jake:比炸弹好吃
Jake: Better than a bomb.
其他人：比我们学校附近那个好吃
Others: Better than the one near our school.
Jake:卤煮
Jake: Braised tofu.
Shure: 不要信他的杨老板
Shure: Don't believe him, Jake.
Shure: 他不专业
Shure: He's not professional.
Shure: 我怎么插
Shure: How do I insert this?
Shure: 插不进去啊
Shure: It won't go in.
Alice:嗯油油
Alice: It's oily.
Shure: 是因为他
Shure: It's because of him.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:应该还有个腐乳
Alice: There should be another fermented tofu.
Shure: 懂了技巧不行
Shure: Got it, the technique isn't right.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这是什么肺子吗
Shure: 嗯
Alice:是的
Jake:你为什么不吃卤猪
Jake:好丑呀好丑
Shure: 你不能以貌取人
Lucia: 我吃到血味了
Shure: never扎着book by its cover
修硕（歌声）：it's been a long day
Jake:这丑吗
Tasha: 可他都是大肠小肠大脑小脑的感觉
其他人：瞧不起谁呢
其他人：谁没有一个东西
Tasha: 那你为什么把别人吃下肚
Jake:它有3种是吧大肠肝
Jake:是肺肺
Shure: 肺然后还有火烧
Jake:哦
其他人：这是豆腐吗
Shure: 对豆腐豆干
Shure: Yeah, tofu and dried tofu.
Tasha: 火烧是什么
Tasha: What's "huoshao"?
Tasha: 是哪个部位啊
Tasha: Which part is it?
Jake:面啊
Jake: It's bread.
Lucia: 我也想问
Lucia: I wanted to ask too.
Lucia: 火烧是哪个部位
Lucia: Which part is "huoshao"?
Shure: 对这面块块就是火烧
Shure: Yeah, this bread is called "huoshao".
Tasha: 啊是什么
Tasha: Ah, what is it?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Jake:面
Jake: Bread.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:就驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉和火烧
Jake: It's just donkey meat and "huoshao".
Jake:就是驴肉火烧
Jake: It's donkey meat "huoshao".
Lucia: 是这样的吗
Lucia: Is it like this?
Jake:煎驴肉就是那个东西
Jake: Fried donkey meat is that thing.
Shure: 他都在底下
Shure: It's all at the bottom.
Shure: 这个嗯
Shure: This, yeah.
Jake:是吧你看
Jake: Right? See.
Shure: 就是面面面饼饼
Shure: It's just bread, bread.
Tasha: 这个就是
Tasha: So this is it.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:对用火烧出来的面
Jake: Yes, the bread made by roasting with fire.
Lucia: 好神奇啊
Lucia: So amazing!
Shure: 好神奇啊
Shure: So amazing!
Lucia: 出感叹
Lucia: I'm impressed.
Shure: 杨老板小课堂开课了
Shure: Jake's little classroom is starting.
Shure: 孩子咳嗽老不好
Shure: The kid's cough just won't go away.
Shure: 多半是肺了
Shure: It's probably the lungs.
Jake:多半是没吃过牛肉火烧
Jake: Probably never had beef roast.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：网友说是一个河北人带来的
Others: The netizens say it was brought by a guy from Hebei.
其他人：炉火烧肉
Others: Roasted meat.
其他人：是真他妈好吃
Others: It's really damn good.
Jake:怎么带过来的就
Jake: How did he bring it over?
其他人：就他带过来
Others: He just brought it.
其他人：就是冷的都很好吃
Others: Even when it's cold, it's really good.
Shure: 好帅
Shure: So cool.
Jake:这3个东西
Jake: These three things.
Jake:你们用了吗
Jake: Have you used them?
Shure: 用了
Shure: Yes, I have.
Jake:用了
Jake: Used them.
Shure: 你把蒜汁和那个辣椒油浇了就行
Shure: Just pour the garlic sauce and that chili oil.
Shure: 那个韭菜花一般不加
Shure: Usually, you don't add the leek flower sauce.
其他人：太专业了
Others: So professional.
Shure: low口
Shure: Low-key.
其他人：从妈妈肚子里就在吃
Others: Eating from mom's womb.
Shure: 必须的
Shure: Absolutely.
Jake:吃啥呀腐乳
Jake: What are we eating, fermented tofu?
Alice:腐乳
Alice: Fermented tofu.
Jake:腐乳加吗
Jake: Adding fermented tofu?
Shure: 腐乳不加
Shure: Don't add fermented tofu.
Jake:不加好
Jake: Not adding it is better.
Shure: 也可以尝试
Shure: You can try it though.
Shure: 但我没加过
Shure: But I've never added it.
Shure: 我不够漏口
Shure: I'm not low-key enough.
Jake:咱要不顺势把豆汁撒在床上
Jake: Should we just pour the soy milk on the bed?
Lucia: 我们买豆汁了吗
Lucia: Did we buy soy milk?
Jake:买豆浆了吗
Jake: Did we buy soy milk?
Tasha: 买了一瓶吧
Tasha: We bought a bottle, right?
Jake:买了一瓶
Jake: Bought a bottle.
Jake:又买了一瓶
Jake: Bought another bottle.
Alice:不是买了一瓶吗
Alice: Didn't you already buy one?
Jake:在哪呢走来
Jake: Where is it? Bring it over.
Jake:先说要吃完吗
Jake: Did you say you wanted to finish it?
Jake:别的吃不了
Jake: Can't eat anything else.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：我吃不了一点不是
Others: I can't eat even a bit, right?
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 吃饱了再喝那个不是危险性更大吗
Lucia: Isn't it more dangerous to drink that after eating too much?
Shure: 喂一下就
Shure: Just feed a bit.
Lucia: 哈哈哈说这么直白干什么
Lucia: Hahaha, why say it so bluntly?
Tasha: 已经要吐了
Tasha: I'm about to throw up.
Shure: 我不吃我不吃
Shure: I won't eat, I won't eat.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我没吃过
Lucia: I've never eaten it.
其他人：我怕吃完咱们又泼一杯了
Others: I'm afraid we'll spill another cup after eating.
Jake:吃啥
Jake: Eat what?
Alice:节奏
Alice: Rhythm.
Alice:下午直接走那次在街头买了一一袋
Alice: In the afternoon, went straight out and bought a bag on the street.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:接头一单
Jake: One bag on the street.
其他人：这个活必须我来干
Others: This job has to be done by me.
其他人：我不能
Others: I can't.
Tasha: 我们同学三个人去买了一罐
Tasha: Three of us classmates went to buy a can.
其他人：我不能让私藏货币的事情给给别人做
Others: I can't let the secret currency hoarding be done by others.
Tasha: 当时说是什么味来着
Tasha: What was the taste at that time?
Tasha: 反正中午吃的全部都吐了
Tasha: Anyway, everything we ate at noon was vomited out.
Lucia: 听起来好危险
Lucia: Sounds so dangerous.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This.
Shure: 真的会在几十年后让我们财富自由吗
Shure: Will this really make us financially free in decades?
Jake:这个怎么怎么炒啊
Jake: How to hype this up?
其他人：你相你相信30年后财务自由
Others: Do you believe in financial freedom in 30 years?
其他人：不如相信你能活到30年
Others: Better believe you'll live to 30 years.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 我应该差不多吧
Shure: I think I can probably make it.
Shure: 50岁我还活不到吗
Shure: Can't I live to 50?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人：这他妈能活吗
Others: Can this really be lived?
Shure: 那差不多啊
Shure: That's about right.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 而且还要考虑通货膨胀因素
Lucia: And we also need to consider inflation.
Shure: 这币很珍惜
Shure: This coin is very precious.
Shure: 这边只有150个
Shure: There are only 150 of them here.
其他人：到时候让马斯克看看
Others: Let Musk take a look at it then.
其他人：上了让马斯克在推上发一句话
Others: Get Musk to tweet about it.
其他人：这币就能涨他妈一一万个币
Others: Then this coin can go up like crazy.
Tasha: 一钩币
Tasha: One hook coin.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
其他人：有一天
Others: One day.
Lucia: 那就得
Lucia: Then it has to be...
Lucia: 这个监制的任务就得交给杨老板了
Lucia: The producer's job will have to go to Jake.
其他人：有一天我跟你说
Others: One day I'm telling you...
Tasha: 真的会发行150个虚拟币吗
Tasha: Will they really issue 150 virtual coins?
其他人：有一天就是大
Others: One day it will be big.
Lucia: 有一天就是大一的时候
Lucia: One day, when we are freshmen.
其他人：一的时候
Others: When we are freshmen.
Jake:是发150个币
Jake: Yes, we are issuing 150 coins.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：大一的时候
Others: When we are freshmen.
其他人 ：张晨他晚上睡得很晚
Others: Zhang Chen goes to bed really late.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 真的吗
其他人：然后张晨来刷推特
Others: Then Zhang Chen checks Twitter.
其他人Shure: 看见了马斯克说屎逼
Others/Shure: Saw Musk say "shitcoin".
其他人：你知道那个逼吗
Others: Do you know that coin?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：妈的张晨当时就刷到了
Others: Damn, Zhang Chen saw it at that time.
其他人：其实其实我没睡
Others: Actually, I wasn't asleep.
其他人：但是他以为我睡
Others: But he thought I was asleep.
其他人：他没跟我说
Others: He didn't tell me.
其他人：那个时候
Others: At that time.
其他人：在那个时候在比亚都没那个屎逼
Others: At that time, there wasn't that "shitcoin" on Binance.
其他人：马上他直接下了个小小交易所
Others: He immediately downloaded a small exchange.
其他人：赶快买了2,000的水
Others: Quickly bought $2,000 worth.
其他人：一觉醒来就憋8,000了
Others: Woke up and it was worth $8,000.
其他人：中妈赚钱不给兄弟赚还傻逼
Others: Not making money for your buddies makes you an idiot.
其他人：确实逆天
Others: Truly defies the odds.
Shure: 冻成花了
Shure: It's freezing!
其他人：之前还听当时一直在宿舍挖梨胎坊
Others: Before, we heard you were always digging for pear embryos in the dorm.
其他人：挖了个小一圈
Others: Dug a small circle.
其他人：把我显卡挖劈了
Others: My graphics card got split.
其他人：我修
Others: I repaired it.
其他人：维修的时候人家问你这显卡为什么
Others: When repairing, they asked why your graphics card
其他人：两道黑杠
Others: has two black lines.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Jake:有什么卡吗
Jake: Do you have any cards?
其他人：303060 哎
Others: 303060, oh yeah.
Jake:就就我给你了哈哈
Jake: I gave it to you, haha.
其他人：哈哈哈不不不
Others: Haha, no, no, no.
其他人：这是个傻狗
Others: This is a dumb dog.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:他电怎么样还
Jake: How's the battery?
Lucia: 他怎么还是没有记录
Lucia: Why isn't it recording yet?
Jake:没连上
Jake: Not connected.
Lucia: 我VPN怎么好像又哎挂着了呀
Lucia: Why does it seem like my VPN is hanging again?
Lucia: 那他怎么
Lucia: What should I do?
Jake:关了再开
Jake: Turn it off and on again.
Lucia: 我手机快没存储空间了
Lucia: My phone is running out of storage space.
Jake:清掉
Jake: Clear some space.
Lucia: 我存了好多素材不能加
Lucia: I have a lot of files saved, can't delete them.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:导出来
Jake: Export them.
Lucia: 啊他确实在charging 98%
Lucia: Ah, it's actually charging, 98%.
Lucia: 早上怎么还好像还是100%呀
Lucia: Why was it still 100% this morning?
Lucia: 他是不是充的没有他耗的快呀
Lucia: Is it charging slower than it's draining?
Jake:嗯没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:一个小时下减20%可以接受了哈哈哈
Jake: Losing 20% in an hour is acceptable, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈OK
Lucia: Hahaha, okay.
Lucia: 那么有人喝豆汁吗
Lucia: Does anyone want to drink fermented soy milk?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:可以晚一些
Jake: Maybe later.
Lucia: 你喝过吗
Lucia: Have you ever tried it?
Jake:我喝过
Jake: I have.
Lucia: 你喝过啊
Lucia: You have?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 可是你看起来
Lucia: But you look...
Lucia: 好像他并没有任何心理阴影的样子
Lucia: Like you don't have any psychological trauma from it.
Shure: 喂喂爹
Shure: Hey, hey, dad.
Jake:呃就大不了吐了吧
Jake: Well, at worst, I'll just throw up.
Shure: 你说那个
Shure: You mean that...
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Huh?
Jake:哈哈哈多大事吧哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, it's no big deal, haha.
Shure: 帮我把电脑开一下呗
Shure: Can you turn on my computer for me?
Lucia: 不是情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: Why is he so emotionally stable?
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Huh?
Shure: 刚刚不是开过了吗
Shure: Didn't you turn it on earlier?
Shure: 但是你没有解锁
Shure: But you didn't unlock it.
Lucia: 情绪怎么这么稳定啊
Lucia: Why is he so emotionally stable?
Shure: 啊你不是要远程吗
Shure: Oh, you need to remote access it, right?
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 我就没没给你关
Shure: I didn't turn it off for you.
Lucia: 卡皮巴拉转世
Lucia: Reincarnated as a capybara.
Shure: 你得解锁完才能
Shure: You have to unlock it first.
Jake:吐一下怎么了哈哈哈
Jake: What's wrong with spitting, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈你说到卡皮巴拉
Lucia: Haha, you mentioned capybara.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Lucia: 我这里有一个特别可爱的表情包
Lucia: I have a super cute emoji.
Jake:我我要学
Jake: I want to learn.
Shure: 5426883还是87877
Shure: Is it 5426883 or 87877?
Jake:一下这到底是个什么玩意
Jake: What is this thing anyway?
Lucia: 哦我给你看
Lucia: Oh, let me show you.
Lucia: 我发给你我发给你
Lucia: I'll send it to you, I'll send it to you.
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 你在哪呢
Lucia: Where are you?
Jake:我真不知道
Jake: I really don't know.
Shure: 然后帮我把那个向日葵开开
Shure: Then help me turn on that sunflower.
Jake:在这在这在这在这
Jake: Here, here, here.
Lucia: 找不着你了
Lucia: I can't find you.
Lucia: 不是我给你看那个表情包
Lucia: No, let me show you that emoji.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 在这找到你
Lucia: Found you here.
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 这个是这是这这个吧
Lucia: Is this it?
Katrina: 对对对对水豚
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes, capybara.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 我从我朋友那里捞来的一个表情包
Lucia: I got this emoji from a friend.
Lucia: 下午好有什么倒忙是我能帮的吗哈
Lucia: Good afternoon, is there anything I can help with? Haha.
Jake:有什么倒忙是需要我能帮的吗
Jake: Is there anything you need help with?
Shure: 我打打打
Shure: I'm playing, playing, playing.
Shure: 屁游戏我看一眼啊
Shure: A game, let me check it out.
Lucia: 哈就这个动物
Lucia: Yeah, this animal.
Lucia: 它情绪特别稳定
Lucia: It has very stable emotions.
Jake:这个是它
Jake: This is it.
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Jake:为什么叫
Jake: Why is it called...
Lucia: 它很可爱
Lucia: It's very cute.
Shure: 可以了没问题
Shure: It's fine, no problem.
Jake:它的学名就叫这个名字
Jake: Its scientific name is this?
Lucia: 它学名就叫卡皮巴拉吧好像
Lucia: Its scientific name is capybara, I think.
Jake:它叫水豚
Jake: It's called a capybara.
Jake:水豚那为什么叫巴拉
Jake: Capybara, so why is it called "Bala"?
Shure: 阿里嘎斗
Shure: Arigato.
Jake:巴拉是什么
Jake: What does "Bala" mean?
Shure: 谢谢爹
Shure: Thank you, dad.
Lucia: 英语翻译过来好像
Lucia: The English translation seems like...
Shure: 你滚你滚
Shure: Get out, get out.
Shure: 你别开别瞎开
Shure: Don't just mess around.
Lucia: 哦他
Lucia: Oh, he...
Lucia: 好像他英语就叫卡皮巴拉
Lucia: It seems that in English it's called capybara.
Shure: 好拜拜
Shure: Okay, bye.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something like that.
Lucia: 是吗好像是他
Lucia: Is it? Seems like it is.
Katrina: 反正有个BGM总
Katrina: Anyway, there's always this BGM.
Lucia: 有个BGM总是这样配的
Lucia: There's always this BGM.
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yeah, that's it.
Jake:它为什么是水豚
Jake: Why is it a capybara?
Jake:它是在水里的吗
Jake: Is it because it lives in the water?
Katrina: 是这样会
Katrina: Yeah, that's probably why.
Jake:是的是它怎么
Jake: Yes, so how...
Lucia: 的是他
Lucia: That's why...
Lucia: 超可爱我觉得好像小马
Lucia: It's super cute, I think it looks like a little horse.
Jake:嗯好像小马小驴刚吃过
Jake: Yeah, like a small horse or donkey after eating.
Lucia: 这个可以吃吗
Lucia: Can you eat this?
Lucia: 应该不可以吃
Lucia: Probably can't eat it.
Shure: 它好像不是什么保护动物
Shure: I don't think it's a protected animal.
Lucia: 这种那个
Lucia: This kind of...
Lucia: 那个字念什么
Lucia: How do you pronounce that character?
Lucia: 啮齿还是什么类啮
Lucia: Is it rodent or something like that?
Shure: 啮齿类
Shure: Rodent.
Lucia: 对那个动物那那一类的都不可以吃吧
Lucia: Yeah, animals in that category probably can't be eaten, right?
Lucia: 一般来说
Lucia: Generally speaking.
Katrina: 电量特别低的时候是开
Katrina: When the battery is very low...
Katrina: 开不了的吗
Katrina: It can't be turned on?
Katrina: 但是他在充电
Katrina: But it's charging.
Jake:没有他就是他得一直亮着他才充电
Jake: No, it has to stay on for it to charge.
Jake:你现在才还是100%
Jake: Now it's still at 100%.
Lucia: 如果很低的话
Lucia: If it's very low...
Jake:显然是没有充的
Jake: Obviously, it's not charging.
Lucia: 如果很低的话他现在开不了
Lucia: If it's very low, it can't be turned on now.
Lucia: 他得充一会才能再
Lucia: It needs to charge for a while before it can be used again.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:就是你虽然是插上了但是他没有充
Jake: Even though it's plugged in, it's not charging.
Jake:他没有开机充电
Jake: It's not charging because it wasn't turned on.
Jake:网没有开
Jake: The network wasn't on.
Jake:就他一点电都没有耗嘛对吧
Jake: So it didn't use any power at all, right?
Shure: copy pa la      copy pa lacopy pa lacopy pa lacopy pa la
Shure: Copy pa la, copy pa la, copy pa la, copy pa la.
Lucia: 10级冲浪大师
Lucia: Level 10 surfing master.
Katrina: 一天24小时28小时上网
Katrina: Online 28 hours a day.
Lucia: 28小时上网
Lucia: Online 28 hours a day.
Lucia: 我们这里的AI好多呀
Lucia: We have a lot of AIs here.
Shure: 我我
Shure: I, I...
Lucia: 全天候在线
Lucia: Always online.
Jake:只是插根网线
Jake: Just plug in a network cable.
Jake:就我们插的是电线他插的是网线
Jake: We plug in a power cable, he plugs in a network cable.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 跟我的云服务器已经同步了现在
Shure: It's already synced with my cloud server now.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 不我不是AI
Lucia: No, I'm not an AI.
Lucia: 我只是一直输了
Lucia: I just keep losing.
Jake:你是什么环境
Jake: What kind of environment are you in?
Lucia: 哈哈哈还这个
Lucia: Haha, still this.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么了谢宾竹
Shure: What's up, Xie Binzhu?
Shure: 邢秘书刚才叫我
Shure: Secretary Xing just called me.
Katrina: 没叫你啊
Katrina: He didn't call you.
Shure: 他不是 修硕吗
Shure: Isn't he Shure?
Lucia: 他你可你可能收到了他的无限讯号
Lucia: You might have received his infinite signal.
Shure: 他在下面讲你可能收到他的无限讯号
Shure: He was speaking downstairs, you might have received his infinite signal.
Lucia: 他在下面真的讲啊
Lucia: He was really speaking downstairs.
Katrina: 没听见他喊啊
Katrina: I didn't hear him shout.
Jake:我也没听见好强
Jake: I didn't hear either. So strong.
Lucia: 我也没听见
Lucia: I didn't hear it either.
Katrina: 你俩心灵感应啊
Katrina: Are you two telepathic?
Jake:你们是哪个频段频段的
Jake: Which frequency band are you guys on?
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 我们是5 Giga Beats赫兹
Shure: We're on 5 Giga Beats Hertz.
Jake:多少赫兹
Jake: How many Hertz?
Shure: 5 Giga赫兹
Shure: 5 Giga Hertz.
Jake:可以
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 我要搜啥来着啊腾讯云
Shure: What am I supposed to search for again? Oh, Tencent Cloud.
Jake:我们还缺什么要买的吗
Jake: Do we need to buy anything else?
Jake:下午采购去
Jake: Let's go shopping in the afternoon.
Jake:有必要吗
Jake: Is it necessary?
Shure: 可以远程
Shure: We can do it remotely.
Shure: 盒马的这次
Shure: Hema this time.
Lucia: 盒马送货上门啊
Lucia: Hema delivers to your door, right?
Jake:咱要不换一家总盒马的
Jake: Should we switch to another store? We always use Hema.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 主要盒马
Shure: Mainly Hema.
Shure: 算是国内唯一一个这么好用的商超
Shure: It's pretty much the only really good supermarket in the country.
Shure: 能和
Shure: It can...
Shure: 也不能说能和山姆什么的
Shure: Actually, it can't really compare with Sam's.
Lucia: 河马不是一直是那个谁
Lucia: Isn't Hema always under...
Lucia: 阿里那边的吗
Lucia: Ali's management?
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Lucia: 今年淘宝
Lucia: This year, Taobao...
Shure: MSTN
Lucia: 今年年初的时候开始
Lucia: At the beginning of this year...
Lucia: 淘宝也一直在搞新的市场
Lucia: Taobao has been expanding its market.
Lucia: 市场攻略
Lucia: Market strategies.
Shure: 为什么我这个c键就输不进去呢我操
Shure: Why can't I type the letter 'c'? Damn it.
Lucia: 我们除了奶油还要买什么来着
Lucia: Besides cream, what else do we need to buy?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:得问问他都
Jake: We should ask him...
Shure: 显腿细
Shure: Makes your legs look slim.
Jake:买啥呀买啥呀
Jake: What to buy, what to buy...
Katrina: 谁会喜欢55岁老头啊
Katrina: Who would like a 55-year-old man?
Lucia: 咱冰箱里还有两块牛排呢
Lucia: We still have two steaks in the fridge.
Katrina: 嘿嘿好帅
Katrina: Haha, he's so handsome.
Shure: 操
Shure: Damn.
Katrina: 你看这这像55岁的吗
Katrina: Look, does this look like a 55-year-old?
Shure: 确实
Shure: True.
Shure: 感觉我55岁也差不多这个样子
Shure: I feel like I'll look like this when I'm 55 too.
Shure: 迷倒一片老太太
Shure: Charming a bunch of old ladies.
Katrina: 55岁在抱着那吉他上人民公园
Katrina: Playing guitar in People's Park at 55.
Shure: 五三岁
Shure: Fifty-three.
Katrina: 去唱摇滚去
Katrina: Singing rock and roll.
Katrina: 哈哈哈你说我有5个EGO币
Jake:靠那5个EGO币
Jake:活下活下半身
Jake: Live, live a half life
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 以后相亲
Katrina: In the future, when dating
Jake:活下半身
Jake: Live a half life
Katrina: 简历上面写本人有5个EGO币
Shure: 这边开了两个远程桌面
Shure: I've opened two remote desktops here
Jake:BGM吗这是
Jake: Is this the BGM?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, yes
Alice:北京野生动物园
Alice: Beijing Wildlife Park
Alice:不是有那个卡比巴拉吗
Alice:好多人去跟他合影
Alice: Lots of people go take pictures with it
Alice:就拿个水果啊啥顶在它的头上
Alice: They put a fruit or something on its head
Alice:反而它也不动
Alice: And it doesn't move
Alice:就是活也可以不死
Alice: It can live without dying
Katrina: 不活也行
Katrina: Or not live, it's fine
Alice:不活也行
Alice: Or not live, it's fine
Alice:哈哈哈活着也行死了也行
Alice: Hahaha, living is fine, dying is fine too
Alice:随便你就你这种精神状态
Alice: Whatever you want, with your mental state
Lucia: 领先人类100年
Lucia: Ahead of humans by 100 years
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:放个榴莲在头上
Jake: Put a durian on its head
Alice:哈哈顶橘子就橘子上面再放橘子
Alice: Haha, put an orange, then another orange on top
Shure: 榴莲好像他顶着有点费劲
Shure: Durian might be a bit difficult to balance
Alice:就像顶杂技一样
Alice: Like a balancing act
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Alice:就不不动不管
Alice: It doesn't move, doesn't care
Alice:淡淡的死亡感
Alice: A faint sense of death
Alice:活着也行不活也行随便你
Alice: Living is fine, not living is fine, whatever
Alice:下午什么安排
Alice: What's the plan for the afternoon?
Alice:买东西
Alice: Shopping
Alice:估计快递也快到
Alice: The delivery should be arriving soon
Jake:拆快递
Jake: Unpack the delivery
Jake:你们拆快递
Jake: You guys unpack the delivery
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys
Alice:该布置了
Alice: Time to set up
Jake:布置那个问答
Jake: Set up the Q&A
Alice:还要收拾
Alice: Still need to tidy up
Jake:问答的话GPT得干活啊
Jake: For the Q&A, GPT has to work
Lucia: PPT出完我们来检查一下吧
Lucia: Once the PPT is done, let's check it
Lucia: 要不然他胡说八道
Lucia: Otherwise, he's just talking nonsense.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:每天都让他有一个胡说八道的机会
Jake: He gets a chance to talk nonsense every day.
Lucia: 每天都
Lucia: Every day?
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Alice:还是不知道为什么
Alice: Still don't know why.
Alice:那个什么一多少来着
Alice: What's that number again?
Jake:132132 是回文数
Jake: 132132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 132为什么是
Lucia: Why is 132...
Alice:还有那个为什么代表3月21
Alice: And why does it represent March 21?
Jake:也没整明白
Jake: No idea.
Alice:为什么能用16多少来着代表
Alice: Why can it be used to represent...
Jake:对这真是太离谱了这个
Jake: Yeah, this is really outrageous.
Lucia: 一个
Lucia: A...
Alice:161 还是161吧
Alice: 161, or is it 161?
Lucia: 啊好像是
Lucia: Oh, seems like it.
Alice:为什么呢
Alice: Why though?
Jake:是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:他是说
Jake: He said...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:他是这么说的
Jake: That's what he said.
Jake:161 这个数字代表国际植树节3月21号
Jake: 161 represents International Day of Forests on March 21.
Jake:尽管他与世界第九日不是同一天哈
Jake: Although it's not the same day as World Earth Day.
Alice:哈哈哈那我是不是还能代表328
Alice: Haha, then can it represent March 28 too?
Alice:尽管他们不是同一个数字哈哈哈
Alice: Even though they are not the same number, haha.
Jake:哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:是这么回事哈哈哈
Jake: That's how it is, haha.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 他哪怕把那个3月21除以2我都能接受
Lucia: Even if he divided March 21 by 2, I could accept that.
Lucia: 他给了一个什么奇怪的东西
Lucia: He came up with some weird number.
Jake:139 这个数字
Jake: 139, this number...
Jake:象征着地球大气中主要气体的数量
Jake: Represents the number of main gases in the Earth's atmosphere.
Lucia: 是139种吗
Lucia: Are there 139 kinds?
Jake:我觉得不是
Jake: I don't think so.
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Lucia: 不是一共就那么几种吗
Lucia: Aren't there just a few kinds in total?
Jake:他应该是组
Jake: He might have grouped...
Alice:他说气体数量
Alice: He said the number of gases.
Jake:组了一个什么CO2
Jake: Grouped something like CO2.
Jake:是吧对
Jake: Right, yeah.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is it?
Jake:192
Jake: 192
Jake:这个数字
Jake: This number
Jake:可以象征全世界
Jake: Can represent the whole world
Jake:大概有192个国家
Jake: There are about 192 countries
Alice:元素
Alice: Elements
Jake:需要参加世界第九日的活动
Jake: Need to participate in the World Ninth Day event
Jake:这是是吗
Jake: Is that right?
Lucia: 只有192个国家
Lucia: Only 192 countries
Alice:一共
Alice: In total
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know
Jake:得200多吧我感觉
Jake: I feel like there are over 200
Alice:有的没资格参加吗
Alice: Are some not qualified to participate?
Alice:这意思吗
Alice: Is that what you mean?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈不知道啊
Lucia: Hahaha, I don't know
Jake:啊是吧
Jake: Oh, is that right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈咱也不知道啊我是
Lucia: Hahaha, we don't know either
Jake:108 在许多文化中
Jake: 108, in many cultures
Jake:108是个神圣的数字
Jake: 108 is a sacred number
Jake:象征着宇宙的和谐和完整
Jake: Symbolizing the harmony and completeness of the universe
Lucia: 啊真的吗
Lucia: Oh really?
Jake:也也代表着
Jake: It also represents
Lucia: 我刚想到的是水浒里面的好汉
Lucia: What I just thought of was the heroes from "Water Margin"
Jake:对就这个水浒宇宙的完整
Jake: Yes, the completeness of the "Water Margin" universe
Lucia: great
Lucia: Great
Shure: 水浒宇宙可还行
Shure: The "Water Margin" universe, really?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:没问题吧
Jake: No problem, right?
Alice:没问题
Alice: No problem
Jake:没问题水
Jake: No problem, Water
Lucia: 没问题写万事皆可宇宙
Lucia: No problem, write "everything is the universe"
Jake:水乎宇宙
Jake: "Water Margin" universe
Lucia: 都是那两个漫画公司折腾出来的破事
Lucia: It's all those two comic companies' mess
Lucia: 不过我从我从高中开始看DC和漫威
Lucia: But I've been watching DC and Marvel since high school
Lucia: 然后一直看到现在
Lucia: And I've been watching ever since
Lucia: 然后每天都每天都在
Lucia: And every day, every day
Shure: OK牛逼了家人们
Shure: OK, that's awesome, everyone
Lucia: 就是精神股东
Lucia: Just a spiritual shareholder.
Lucia: 和期待这两个公司破产的边缘摇摆
Lucia: And expecting these two companies to teeter on the brink of bankruptcy.
Lucia: 因为我觉得你们写出来那种狗屎故事
Lucia: Because I think the stories you wrote are such crap.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不然还是别编了哈哈哈
Lucia: Otherwise, just stop making them up, hahaha.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: There's one more.
Jake:这个 197
Jake: This 197.
Jake:这个数字代表1970年
Jake: This number represents the year 1970.
Jake:那一年首次庆祝的地球日
Jake: That year was the first celebration of Earth Day.
Jake:这个数字具有重要的历史和纪念意义
Jake: This number has significant historical and commemorative meaning.
Jake:看对不对
Jake: See if that's right.
Lucia: 我估计他就是算准了
Lucia: I guess he just calculated it right.
Lucia: 有些东西你也不能确定
Lucia: Some things you can't be sure about.
Lucia: 所以他就在这乱说
Lucia: So he's just talking nonsense.
Jake:对他就是乱说
Jake: Yeah, he's just talking nonsense.
Jake:这个确实是真的 1970年
Jake: This is actually true, 1970.
Shure: 这是谁唱
Shure: Who's singing this?
Shure: 大张伟唱的是吗
Shure: Is it sung by Da Zhang Wei?
Shure: 怎么跟大张伟那死动静似的呢
Shure: Why does it sound like Da Zhang Wei's style?
Shure: 把这个大屏幕打开然后
Shure: Turn on the big screen and then...
Shure: 想想地球日的题目
Shure: Think about the topic for Earth Day.
Jake:行啊来吧
Jake: Alright, let's do it.
Jake:谁有那什么账号
Jake: Who has that account?
Shure: 哎把那俩遥控器给我去
Shure: Hey, give me those two remotes.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Jake:遥控器是在这
Jake: The remote is over here.
Jake:所以他开了是吧
Jake: So he turned it on, right?
Lucia: 问大家132为什么是回文书
Lucia: Ask everyone why 132 is a palindrome.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake:嗯哦
Jake: Yeah, oh.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:问问他是吧
Jake: Ask him, right?
Lucia: 对就把这个做
Lucia: Yeah, just make this.
Jake:我再问一下
Jake: I'll ask again.
Lucia: 不是把这个作为一个题目
Lucia: No, make this a topic.
Jake:哈哈哈让大家乱编
Jake: Hahaha, let everyone make it up.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 对对对我可能会被全场人打神经病
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, I might get called crazy by everyone.
Jake:人均GBT哈哈哈
Jake: Everyone's GBT, hahaha.
Jake:人均GBT
Jake: Everyone's GBT.
Jake:弱智娃
Jake: Silly kid
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake:我们要不就弱智娃
Jake: Let's just go with silly kid
Jake:题目里面抽几个得了哈哈哈
Jake: And pick a few from the questions, hahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 我又想起来昨天那个北京是什么
Lucia: I just remembered that thing from yesterday, what was Beijing
Lucia: 我说直辖市
Lucia: I said it's a municipality
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 我没看到他指的那辆车
Lucia: I didn't see the car he was pointing at
Lucia: 我以为你
Lucia: I thought you
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake:太典型了这个哈哈
Jake: This is so typical, haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 我以为你真的在正儿八经的问
Lucia: I thought you were seriously asking
Jake:哈正儿八经的
Jake: Seriously asking
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 所以对
Lucia: So yeah
Jake:问北京市
Jake: Asking Beijing
Lucia: 然后我就没有感觉到这个问题的意义
Lucia: Then I didn't understand the point of the question
Jake:就送来一个正确的回答
Jake: So I just gave a correct answer
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Lucia: 对啊这个肯定不会出错吧
Lucia: Yeah, that can't be wrong, right?
Lucia: 谁知道你问的是车呢
Lucia: Who knew you were asking about the car
Jake:所以试试
Jake: So try
Jake:吧那个车
Jake: That car
Lucia: 不知道不了解
Lucia: I don't know, no idea
Lucia: 就是有一个车牌子叫北京
Lucia: There's a car brand called Beijing
Lucia: 汽车厂牌
Lucia: Automobile brand
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hehe
Lucia: 现在是冷笑话时间了是
Lucia: Is it cold joke time now?
Alice:hahahaha
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Hehe
Shure: 太蠢了什么东西
Shure: This is so stupid.
Shure: 哎呦我受不了了
Shure: Oh man, I can't take it.
Shure: 我操太傻逼了
Shure: Damn, this is so dumb.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:就是弱智吧
Jake: It's just idiotic, right?
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else?
Jake:被门夹过的核桃还能还能补
Jake: Can a walnut that's been smashed still be fixed?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:还能补脑
Jake: Still good for the brain.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈多少被蚊炸过
Jake: How many have been crushed by mosquitoes?
Jake:喝杯豆汁压压惊吧哈哈哈
Jake: Have a cup of mung bean milk to calm down, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈我们是要给AIA
Alice: Hahaha, are we going to give AIA...
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:这个已经用起来了
Jake: This is already in use.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:就是AI里边就是有一个研究
Jake: So, in AI, there's a study...
Jake:就是说用弱智吧的这个数据做训练
Jake: Saying that using idiotic data for training...
Lucia: 哦然后呢
Lucia: Oh, and then?
Jake: 效果比别人
Jake: The results are better than others.
Lucia: 你的训练是不是20岁说已经有错了
Lucia: Is your training already wrong at age 20?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哎
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:你这个灯是没有了
Jake: Your light is gone.
Alice:啊灯没有了吗
Alice: The light is gone?
Shure: 哎我的灯怎么变红了啊
Shure: Hey, why did my light turn red?
Jake:啊红的
Jake: Ah, it's red.
Jake:没关系啊
Jake: It's okay.
Shure: 红了是为什
Shure: Why is it red?
Jake:要不你看一下手机对
Jake: Maybe check your phone.
Lucia: 他这个充电宝是不是还有电
Lucia: Is the power bank still charged?
Jake:对你看一下啊这个
Jake: Yeah, check it.
Jake:手机软件
Jake: The phone app.
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴吗
Alice: If a pregnant woman hits someone, is it considered a gang fight?
Alice:孕妇打人算群殴
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Jake:这个点这个很点
Jake: This point, this is the point.
Jake:看看看看看你的这个状态
Jake: Look, look, look at your condition.
Jake:他应该就是过热呀之类的
Jake: It should be overheating or something like that.
Alice:他肚子里有一个哈哈
Alice: There's something in his stomach, haha.
Shure: 过热过热
Shure: Overheating, overheating.
Jake:过热过热
Jake: Overheating, overheating.
Jake:嗯那你就come  down
Jake: Hmm, then you just come down.
Jake:come down
Jake: Come down.
Shure: 我我comedown好像
Shure: I, I comedown, seems like.
Jake:哈哈哈你comedow 然后就
Jake: Hahaha, you comedown and then...
Shure: 哈哈你看不到
Shure: Haha, you can't see.
Shure: 然后他他给我提示说就是quarting停止
Shure: And then he gave me a hint saying the quarting stopped.
Lucia: 但是之前呢
Lucia: But what about before?
Lucia: 这个已经没关系没有stop time
Lucia: It doesn't matter, no stop time.
Jake:哦没关系再开一个吧
Jake: Oh, it's okay, just start another one.
Jake:没关系没关系没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:早上好啊
Jake: Good morning.
Jake:你这还亮着吗
Jake: Is yours still on?
Jake:你这一直不插电
Jake: You've never plugged it in.
Jake:那当然不亮了
Jake: Of course it's not on.
Jake:你不插电
Jake: You didn't plug it in.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:可多了还有吃健胃消食片能吃饱吗
Jake: There's plenty more, can you get full eating digestive tablets?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 客观上来说在胃里是要占空间
Lucia: Objectively speaking, it does take up space in the stomach.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't take it anymore.
Shure: 他怎么卡死了卧槽
Shure: Why is it freezing, damn.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly.
Jake:用这东西来训练AI的话
Jake: If you use this to train AI,
Jake:因为他要回答他就需要很多逻辑
Jake: Because it needs to answer, it requires a lot of logic.
Alice:真的需要很多逻辑
Alice: It really needs a lot of logic.
Alice:你确定吗哈哈
Alice: Are you sure? Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈就是因为训练的时候
Jake: Hahaha, that's because during training,
Jake:会给他一个人写的答案
Jake: It will give it a human-written answer.
Jake:让人写答案
Jake: Let people write answers.
Jake:就是他会一本正经的去回答这个问题
Jake: He would seriously answer this question.
Jake:就是吃健胃消食片什么什么功效
Jake: Like, what are the effects of digestive tablets?
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Alice:笑死了
Alice: That's hilarious.
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吗
Jake: Is infertility hereditary?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 我受不了
Katrina: I can't handle this.
Lucia: 算一下 7除以2不应该是3.5吗
Lucia: Isn't 7 divided by 2 supposed to be 3.5?
Katrina: 忘了9 哦
Katrina: I forgot about 9, oh.
Lucia: 对不起我说9
Lucia: Sorry, I meant 9.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Ugh.
Katrina: 地球上有30%的海洋
Katrina: 30% of the Earth is ocean.
Katrina: 和百分之70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Katrina: And 70% is ocean and 30% is land.
Katrina: 那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地去哪了
Katrina: So where did the remaining 30% ocean and 70% land go?
Jake:啥 70%什么
Jake: What? 70% of what?
Katrina: 地球上有70%的海洋和30%的陆地
Katrina: 70% of the Earth is ocean and 30% is land.
Katrina: 那剩下的30%海洋和70%的陆地是吗
Katrina: So the remaining 30% ocean and 70% land, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:好玩
Jake: That's funny.
Jake:插电了吗
Jake: Is it plugged in?
Jake:好插个电啊
Jake: Okay, plug it in.
Shure: 哎呦别死了一会
Shure: Hey, don't die on me.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 关羽不斩老六
Katrina: Guan Yu didn't kill Lao Liu.
Katrina: 为什么不派十万老六去斩杀关羽
Katrina: Why didn't they send 100,000 Lao Lius to kill Guan Yu?
Shure: 哈哈哈太傻逼了
Shure: Hahaha, that's so dumb.
Shure: 我受不了了
Shure: I can't handle this.
Jake:哈哈这好好有
Jake: Haha, that's so...
Jake:哈哈哈好有道理
Jake: Hahaha, that makes so much sense.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:就出题吧
Jake: Let's come up with a question.
Jake:咱也别世界地球人
Jake: Let's not be global citizens.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈行
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Jake:我明天表演的那个
Jake: My performance tomorrow.
Jake:我明天表演的节目就是给大家讲笑话
Jake: My show tomorrow is just to tell jokes to everyone.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:咱充上了吗
Jake: Did we charge it?
Shure: can i program data again on the account
Shure: Can I program data again on the account?
Jake:咱要不开机
Jake: Should we turn it on?
Jake:又挂了是吧又挂了
Jake: It's down again, right? It's down again.
Lucia: 写遗嘱的时候因为拖延症错过了奶奶
Lucia: Missed my grandma because of procrastination while writing a will.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 怎么办
Lucia: What should I do?
Jake:错过了再来
Jake: Missed it? Do it again.
Katrina: 那真的是呆懒
Katrina: That's really lazy.
Alice:做梦吧哈哈哈
Alice: Dream on, haha.
Jake:然后然后出来问问题
Jake: Then, then come out and ask questions.
Katrina: 心语听力考试
Katrina: Listening exam.
Katrina: 总是听到两个人在广播里唠嗑
Katrina: I always hear two people chatting on the broadcast.
Katrina: 干扰我做题
Katrina: Distracting me.
Katrina: 怎么能把那两个人撵走
Katrina: How can I get rid of them?
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, oh.
Shure: 找不到这个
Shure: Can't find this.
Tasha: 充了没有用的
Tasha: Charging won't help.
Jake:正正月剪头被舅舅制止并暴打一顿
Jake: In January, I got stopped and beaten up by my uncle for getting a haircut.
Jake:舅舅舅是否得逞后正当防卫
Jake: Self-defense after being stopped by uncle.
Shure: 啊还有那个
Shure: Oh, there's that too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈傻傻傻
Lucia: Hahaha, silly, silly.
Shure: 那个秀秀
Shure: That, that show.
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 那个正月剪头不是死舅舅吗
Shure: Isn't getting a haircut in January bad luck for uncles?
Shure: 然后如果呢
Shure: And if I...
Shure: 我正月烫头的话
Shure: What if I get a perm in January?
Shure: 那舅舅会变弯吗哈哈
Shure: Will my uncle turn gay then? Haha 性别问题
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Hah
Alice:过年的时候真的就有这个正月剪头的
Alice: During New Year, there's really this thing about January haircuts.
Alice:然后他舅他舅妈把他侄子给起诉了
Alice: Then his uncle and aunt sued his cousin.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 啊起诉
Lucia: Ah, sued?
Alice:对OK
Alice: Yeah, okay.
Alice:所以觉得就是他剪头让他老公死了
Alice: So they thought the haircut killed her husband.
Alice:他老公刚死了
Alice: Her husband just died.
Alice:真的很容易死
Alice: Really easy to die.
Katrina: 这么容易死啊
Katrina: So easy to die, huh?
Tasha: 真的很容易死啊
Tasha: It's really easy to die.
Alice:他就是这么容易死就抢回了
Alice: He just died so easily and took it back.
Katrina: 这么容易死药也没用
Katrina: Dying so easily, medicine is useless.
Alice:我觉得肯定有抢回
Alice: I think he definitely took it back.
Alice:然后他舅妈真的把他给起诉
Alice: Then his aunt actually sued him.
Katrina: 之前你看过那个台湾的那个综艺没有
Katrina: Have you seen that Taiwanese variety show before?
Jake:了
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 说有一个女生说什么什么打耳洞那边
Katrina: There's a girl talking about getting her ears pierced.
Jake:着火筑下水道
Jake: Burning the sewer.
Katrina: 打耳洞什么克老公
Katrina: Saying ear piercing curses her husband.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 那人说老公这么容易死要老公干什么
Katrina: That person said if the husband dies so easily, why have a husband?
Jake:筑下水道
Jake: Build the sewer.
Katrina: 没看过那个搞笑的超搞笑
Katrina: Haven't seen it, it's super funny.
Jake:好呀
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 我问什么时候
Tasha: I asked when.
Tasha: 你说好呀
Tasha: You said alright.
Jake:我看一看哦
Jake: Let me check.
Tasha: 你不饿
Tasha: Aren't you hungry?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 那口头禅就是好呀
Tasha: Your catchphrase is "alright."
Tasha: 不道呀
Tasha: Don't know.
Tasha: 我有罪对不起哈哈
Tasha: I'm guilty, sorry, haha.
Katrina: 早知道最后被第三志愿录取
Katrina: If I had known, I would have been admitted by my third choice.
Katrina: 第三志愿应该舔清华了
Katrina: Should have aimed for Tsinghua for the third choice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 太傻逼了
Shure: That's so stupid.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 说不出话来
Tasha: Speechless.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
小薇 ：那你就可能被第四志愿录取了
Tasha: Then you might have been admitted by your fourth choice.
Jake:都收波眼镜
Jake: Let's collect the glasses.
Jake:然后倒完咱就走啊
Jake: Then we can leave after we're done.
小薇 ：那我不连了啊
Tasha: Then I won't connect.
Tasha: 刚准备连
Tasha: I was just about to connect.
Jake:你不连了故意的
Jake: You didn't connect on purpose.
Tasha: 这定是上天的安排
Tasha: This must be fate.
Jake:哈哈关关关关掉
Jake: Haha, shut it off, shut it off!
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.